Speaker 1: So we talked at the beginning
of the show. We had this crazy weekend,
including the biggest stock decline of the year
on Friday due to the fears and panic over the
Omicron variant. As I already said, we don't
yet know a long list of important things that we
at some point will know about the Omicron variant.
But needless to say, it caused panic and sell
offs in the stock markets. It also created an
environment over the weekend on right wing media
for an even bigger scale up of COVID and vaccine
disinformation. Now you might be saying, Well,
hold on. How could there be more disinformation on
COVID and on vaccines? They've been doing it for
close to two years. It's still getting even worse.
It continues to get worse and worse, and I'm going
to go through a couple of these instances
with you and we'll talk about some of the
points that are being made now in the context
of Omicron. Republican Congresswoman Nancy Mace
was interviewed on Fox News and her idea was,
Hey, you know what? Maybe instead of vaccines,
people should get sick with COVID because you
are better protected. This is something they've
been saying for a while. Take a listen
to this and see if you can figure out
why it's dangerously irresponsible, as in one
Speaker 3: of the things that the CDC has not
done and no, no policymaker at the federal level
has done so far is taken into account what natural
immunity does, and that may be what we're seeing
in Florida today. In some studies that I've read,
natural immunity gives you twenty seven times
more protection against future COVID infection
than vaccination. And so when you take
all of the science into account and now
Speaker 1: 20, she says, 27 times, I haven't
even been able to find a study that asserts that
I found one study that says recent recovery
gives you 27 percent better protection
than the vaccines, which are tailored to the
original variants. The best is still recovery
plus vaccine. And remember, the vaccine won't
kill you, whereas getting COVID to end up with
immunity might actually kill you.
Speaker 3: Selectively choosing what science
to follow when we are making policy decisions
and you're seeing, I believe Gov. DeSantis is,
you know, seeing the fruit of that labor today.
Speaker 1: OK, yeah, DeSantis has actually done
everything wrong on COVID. But again,
even if it were true that you're
more robustly immune by recovering rather than
getting vaccinated, the process of recovering
naturally can kill you at close to a one percent
rate. Whereas what we know about the vaccines is
there are three people who died from myocarditis
after being vaccinated. It may have been related,
and there have been hundreds of millions
of people in the U.S. vaccinated already.
So it's incredibly irresponsible to say for
Jesus, it's 27 X, even if it's 27 percent
that go through a process through which nearly
one percent will die to get immunity rather than
getting a shot. Very, very irresponsible. And then
lastly, recovered or not, there's sort of like a a
game theory. There's an optimal solution to this,
which is if you haven't recovered from the virus,
you want to get the vaccine to develop immunity.
If you have recovered from the virus, you get
the vaccine and you get even better immunity.
So either way, you get better immunity when
vaccinated. Incredibly irresponsible and dangerous
comments from Nancy Mace. Then we go to Donald
Trump Jr.. Donald Trump Jr. is saying two things
which are crazy. One is that nobody's talking
about the violent protests, riots, anti-vaccine
around the world. That's wrong. I did an entire
segment about it last week. It is being discussed.
And number two, he seems to think that we should
be having that here in the United States.
Speaker 4: Go left. So you don't hear
about these policies, you know, you don't
hear about what's going on as it relates
to the riots in Europe on a daily basis now
against the vaccine mandate because our media
wants to block that out. They're going
to make sure that you never hear about it
because they don't want you getting these kind
of ideas. That freedom may actually still exist
in some parts of the world. I mean, Europe is
pushing back in America, sitting there like sheep.
Oh, you know, this is great. Just go.
Speaker 1: Think about what he's saying,
he's saying there. He's saying riots are good.
Remember, in other contexts, riots are bad
and they can be used to justify shooting
people taking out guns, police being harsh with
protesters. But unless the rioters or Trump is in
which case it wasn't a riot at all, it was antifa
and peaceful. But here he's saying there's
riots going on in Europe against the vaccines,
and those are good, and the media isn't telling
Americans about them because Americans might
realize, Hey, we should do that here. And he says
that would be a good thing. He thinks there should
be riots. It would be good to have riots here
in the U.S. next. Lara Logan was on Fox News,
and she I mean, see if you can find the number of
lies in this statement. And again, this is all the
context is reporting about Omicron failures.
Speaker 3: If you look at Sweden with no
lockdowns and no vaccinations and look
at the death rate there over time,
what they're realizing is they can't.
Speaker 1: OK, so there are it's nine seconds,
guys, and she's lying to you three times.
First of all, no lockdowns in Sweden,
in Sweden without making it policy of the
state. You had these sort of sheltering
Speaker 4: or
Speaker 1: separation
voluntary of the most vulnerable Swedes,
that's number one. But it is true that
bars stayed open and OK, that is true. She says
there's no vaccinations in Sweden. Sweden has more
people vaccinated than the U.S. by percentage. In
the U.S., we're at 59 percent fully vaccinated.
In Sweden, they're at 68 percent fully
vaccinated. She's lying. She said no
vaccines in Sweden reality. More vaccines in
Sweden than in the United States. And she says,
look at the death rate. The death rate in Sweden
has started to creep up, creep up, creep up,
and it's not looking good in Sweden anymore. It's
a very strange idealization of Sweden based on
lies. We'll get back to Lara Logan here. Stephen
Miller, former Trump adviser who says, you know,
if Trump were in office, we would already have
modified vaccines to deal with the new variants,
which isn't true. I mean, just listen to what
the pharmaceutical companies are telling us.
Speaker 4: President Trump was still in
office, by the way, we'd already have
modified vaccines to deal with the new variants,
which is a great point. President Trump brought us
vaccines in record times, which he made voluntary,
not mandatory. And he'd have updates, too.
Speaker 1: OK, there is no evidence
whatsoever that we would already have
modified vaccines for the variants at this time if
Trump were president and the most, you know, the
funniest part of it is, I guess, now vaccines are
good again. All right. Well, when you can attach
them to accomplishments of Trump or imaginary
accomplishments of Trump, the vaccines are good.
Other times, they placate to the most
radical anti-vax people on the Trump side.
Here's an interesting one here's a fox guest who
the discussion is Omicron, and he is able to use
this to talk about non-existent voter fraud
in the last election. How I don't know how
they managed to do it, but they do get
Speaker 4: the benefit of of COVID for the
Democrat Party. They won the last election based
on COVID. They were able to change election rules,
so it made it far easier to cheat and
potentially steal, you know, different
portions of the electorate in the last election.
But the election was stolen. Hold on a second.
So what do I do? I think there was cheating in my
state of Wisconsin. Hell yes, there was cheating.
I'm not going to change the results. I don't know.
You don't know or, you know, because I didn't say,
I didn't say change the election results. I
said, Y'all fight about this in the break.
Speaker 1: I just you kind of just did, he said.
I don't know if it would have changed the election
results. And of course, there is no evidence
that anecdotal all the things that always happen
when 160 million people vote would have changed
the results in even a single county, never mind
a single state. So making taking the Omicron
opportunity to talk about the Big Lie, and then
this is completely off the rails. We're going
back to Lara Logan, who has gone off the deep end
politically. She tells a story about how. There
are corona, hundreds of coronaviruses in bones,
which is related to her having bone cancer,
which isn't funny, but it's not even clear what
argument she's trying to make and basically
saying don't even try to sequence variants.
It's a crazy, crazy thing. And you can see
the doctor on the right side of the screen
starts to look a little bit confused.
Speaker 3: Judge, if
Speaker 1: they, by the way,
that doctor is the one who,
I guess, talk to Trump about his cognitive test.
He's a wacky doctor, and even he finds this nuts.
Speaker 3: Testing for different strains of
coronavirus. We're going to be locked down
for the rest of our existence. I am, you know,
I had cancer. My oncologist is a specialist
in bone cancer. And he, you know, every oncologist
who deals with bone cancer identifies hundreds of
coronaviruses inside of our bones. They've
created a problem that can never actually
be solved so they can justify whatever it is they
want to do. And if you look around you, everything
is falling apart, even though the audits are
going ahead. Durham is moving ahead. Over time,
people can see that the vaccines have nothing to
do with Trump or left or right. Many black people
don't want to get vaccinated. You cannot just by
Speaker 1: the way, that's being repeated. But
it is not black folks who have the lowest
vaccination rate. It's Trump Republicans
Speaker 3: losing three to 5000 Border Patrol
agents, 12000 pilots. You know, it was something
that has the death rate of flu and even.
Speaker 1: And of course, it's not the
death rate of fluids about six times that flu
death rate is about 0.1. Five. COVID death
rate is somewhere between point seven point
eight, so that's very much untrue. This is
Speaker 3: lethal. Americans have the right
under the constitution to their civil liberties,
and they can only be suspended temporarily
and for it to be long. This is not
Speaker 1: totally and completely bonkers. Now,
the one thing that is true about coronaviruses and
bones is that COVID can affect bone growth in
people who have not reached their full size,
so to speak, and can affect bone density. There
are studies about that, so it seems getting COVID
is potentially really bad for the bones. And while
we're still learning more about that, so how long
is this stuff going to go on? Because that every
time that there's something new with the pandemic,
they go back to the same things. The
vaccines are probably not so good.
Guidelines are definitely bad. Trump would have
done everything better, and somehow with with some
cases, it's let's go back to the voter fraud that
they claim stole the election from Trump in 2020.
It's the same playbook just getting recycled over
and over again, truly living in a fantasy world